christian erickson is this uh danish
football or soccer player he plays for
denmark yep
and they're playing finland yeah and in
the middle of the game like right at
halftime he just collapses in the
like on the field yep and then they have
to bring the
like the was the aep machine to like
shock them back to life they gotta do
like harvest hesitation clear
yeah all that [ __ ] the team forms like a
wall around him
his wife comes out on the field they're
like filming her whole thing
he died and basically yeah he died on
the field he died of the field then they
brought him back
brought him back he's like i think
semi-conscious as they're taking them
off he goes to the hospital then they
end the game
yeah and then well they started playing
again yeah fortunately
like after they kind of figured out that
he was like stable in the hospital they
resumed the game
like i think an hour and a half later
yeah and then they finished the game
yeah and then finland won actually so
the team that
he was not on they lost oh no yeah so
kind of a bummer
but it raises horsepower already losing
no zero zero i almost saw my teammate
die you can maybe play in an hour and a
half so that's my question
i'm like you won't see your teammate die
should you play the game that you can
wait a day dog
i mean i would play you should win the
game he's also gotta win the game
yeah exactly yeah because he gets his
all
these other [ __ ] ain't giving
it their all bro like you play to the
point
i mean this is the euros right yeah so
anybody who doesn't care about soccer
which is me as well but every two years
they do
basically a world cup for europe which
is called the euros
yeah they do it every four years sorry
every four years yeah but it's staggered
with the world
cup yeah my bad uh you should probably
explain all this so
but it means a lot to them you know like
you know like america we don't care
about like the nationals like
because we just like who cares eba
international basketball
yeah we don't care about these things
because we're like we know we're going
to win the
the major tournament so why do we care
about this little thing here but uh
in the in europe it really matters like
winning a euro is a huge accomplishment
right like um it could be like a stain
on your legacy
if you don't win a euro right i think i
remember when cristiano won for portugal
right yeah yeah
like he won't even though i'm over him
play in the last game yeah right
but uh but yeah people are like oh wow
that's a huge
leg up that he has on uh messi yeah
messi's never won
like uh whatever cup that world cup like
cope america i don't know if they have
yeah yeah so um okay so this is a big
[ __ ] deal the guy's playing his ass
off he's giving everything yeah
so now a lot of people on twitter are
also pissed because they go oh
why is espn and bbc and all these media
sites why are they broadcasting
him getting resuscitated why not what
else are you gonna broadcast you can't
go to commercials during the soccer game
right that's why
y'all so i'm like you all decided no
commercial breaks it was it was
complicated they were like
they think they don't want to show that
they want to show commercials
they want to make money yeah they're in
the business making money not the
business
[ __ ] get picked up exactly but
there's nothing to do they didn't sell
anything yeah you don't think they want
to have the mcdonald's commercial going
this is also how you get a heart attack
right they would love that but this is
what they have to show
the most action all game this game is
zero zero anyway that's the most
exciting thing that happened
that's funny yeah of course you're gonna
show it
oh my god how do you watch a game of
zero zero at the half that [ __ ] is
do you think that's unethical do you
think that's unethical i don't know it's
conflicting because it's like they're
like showing this they're showing the
wife like crying on tv and it's like
nah that's that's important though wait
what because i mean what if what if
she's some gold digging
[ __ ] that like was about to get half
and she's like yeah don't do that
defibrillator
will you defibrillate him let god work
yeah you know like
that if she was crying that means you
know that she really loves him that's
beautiful okay so in that case
it's how you get a heart attack you're
just running around aren't they in the
best shape
yeah yeah [ __ ] you guys how much he's
going for then that's the other thing
that was wild is that literally the
team's like physician had to come out
like today actually and he was like
he didn't get vaccinated because there
was basically this big twitter
[ __ ] basically being like oh apparently
all the players had to get vaccinated
and then his
physician had to come out and say no and
there is a thing there
no like there was a miscommunication
where he's like does he have to be
vaccinated or not oh
[ __ ] that's the thing i don't understand
though because i thought they all had to
be vaccinated
they were telling nba players to be
vaccinated too and lebron is not
so he's not yo i got i i
it's time to open up the country it's
time to open up the country 100
i started to do the math you said this
like it was a new take no no no but this
is i understand
i know we put out a song but now i did
the math and we really need to open it
have you been bugged about it how's that
equation i'll show you no he got bugged
about him
pills last night and they were supposed
to kick in this morning and they just
kicked in right now so
i have to go take an explosive [ __ ] i've
taken explosive [ __ ] but but real quick
this is why you gotta open up the
country and i'm gonna say it's really
fast because i have to [ __ ] my pants
you have to open up the country this is
why and it's only america and all and
by the way we can open up the country to
other people traveling to us
as well even if you're not vaccinated
whatever you are bring that ass
you are good to come over here okay this
is why we can open up the country
everybody in america who has wanted to
get
the vaccine was able to get it by now at
least one shot you were able to get it
right now
if you haven't been vaccinated by now
it's because you're either lazy
or you're an anti-vaxxer now everybody
who's been vaccinated
is safe to carry on with life as usual
right you have the vaccine
you don't need to wear a mask you need
to do any of these things everybody that
is an anti-vaxxer or refuses to get
vaccinated
has been wanted us to get back to normal
and not wear masks and do that kind of
stuff because they're saying i'm willing
to take the risk i'm willing to take the
risk of getting corona
it's okay run it back so who the [ __ ]
are we protecting
with wear and mass and social distance
policies there's no point anymore
the vaccinated people are like well i'm
doing this so we get back to normal the
people who are not vaccinated are like
son let's get it let's go i'll take the
risk who are we protecting
nobody it's time to open it up
completely there shouldn't be a single
social distance and rule this shouldn't
be a single mask rule everything should
be back to normal
we've had enough time these other
countries that can't get vaccines you do
you
but now everybody could get the vaccine
if they want why did you not
think about this before the song open
her up i thought that was the whole
reason we had the song is you did this
math
i was trying to be provocative i was
trying to get the kids going
you